c'est le principe de séparation des
pouvoirs
une fois élu le président ne peut plus
se rendre ni à l'assemblée ni au sénat
mais en 2008 nicolas sarkozy change les
règles on propose que le chef de l'état
puisse prendre la parole devant le
congrès normalement la réunion des
députés et des sénateurs est dédié aux
réformes constitutionnelles et au vote
d'adhésion d'un état à l'union
européenne sa réforme constitutionnelle
passe in extremis et a pour le moment
été utilisé à deux reprises par nicolas
sarkozy justement en juin 2009 pour
évoquer la crise économique en europe et
par françois hollande en 2015 trois
jours après les attentats de paris avant
eux
françois mitterrand avait utilisé une
astuce en faisant lire son discours par
jacques chaban delmas un moyen de
s'exprimer indirectement face au
parlement
beaucoup de nos concitoyens se pose la
question de savoir comment
fonctionneront les pouvoirs publics à
cette question je ne connais qu'une
réponse
la constitution rien que la constitution
tout cela constitue une possibilité
institutionnelle également utilisé par
les présidents de gaulle et pompidou